what is it you think that makes
independent films send out and why is it
so important to celebrate it it's where
it starts it's where the magic starts
it's where it's where directors and
writers and actors begin if you're born
in this country and you want to be in if
you want to work in the cinema so it's
for me is I do remember watching all the
films in such a short space of time with
with such a privilege because you're
seeing people's work for the first time
and it's so new and it's so fresh and
it's so invigorating and there's nothing
stale about it it's all and it just
feels very exciting it feels like the
future we've talked about other people's
movies let's move on to your own ones
now you've got three great ones coming
up there's only lovers left alive you've
got a new one with Joanna Hogg the
London project and of course we've got
the return of Loki with Thor to the dark
world why he tells a little bit about
each of those
Jim is editing Jim Jarmusch's I just got
a text from him the other day saying he
was editing away and I think it's going
well so I don't know when we'll see that
a bit term I mean only lovers left alive
you're playing a vampire and there
aren't you more complicated I kind of
can't reveal why anyway
DLC and and Joanna is also editing she's
we wrapped in the end of October or
something I think and that I'm really
looking forward to seeing that because I
didn't see a script I just knew what I
was playing this it's one of the first
times I've never seen a full treatment
so but I know vaguely what it's about no
it's your third time you'd be working
with Joanna Hogg on this London project
what keeps bringing you back together I
think she's amazing I just think as a
filmmaker she's incredibly unique and
she makes films inspired by filmmakers
she lives like éric rohmer at yasujiro
ozu and and and I think heard the way
she's tell stories is is very quiet and
very
refined I think she's a very refined
filmmaker idris elba said that thought
is gonna be even bigger and better than
the last movie why don't you tell us a
little bit about him I'm trying to think
of things I could say without ruining it
I mean they go back a long way those to
Thor and Loki they have they have a very
complex and interesting relationship and
they're both still alive and still
capable of feeling things and and so
they'd say they continued to to play
that set the tennis whatever it is and
by what I'm really excited by is it's
not what we've done this time is it it's
you haven't seen this before you really
haven't they're not in Thor not in
Avengers it's a new thing
you